of all the changes and Thor's life one
that's been given too little attention
is a delicate matter of his relationship
with Jane Foster
Jane played a key role in the first two
Thor movies and then suddenly she was
gone here's what happened to Jane and
exactly why Thor doesn't see her anymore
while we might like to think that a
carrots are leaving a series has simply
the product of a mutual parting of ways
behind the camera
it appears that may not be the case here
according to a story from cinema plans
when Portman was brought on to reprise
her role as Jane Foster in Thor the dark
world
she was brimming with enthusiasm at the
thought of working with band director
patty Jenkins she even appears to have
held off on plans to take a break from
acting and spend more time with her
newborn son in order to play her part in
the movie from there however things went
south fairly quickly
Jenkins left a project after two months
and Marvel replaced her with director
Alan Taylor and the change seemed to
leave a bad taste in Portman's mouth
well she did finish principal
photography for the dark world she
subsequently turned down a request to
return for reshoots it's no surprise
then that with the Thor storyline at the
time looking like it might sputter out
Portman would have had very little
motivation to proactively continue her
role in the MCU the mantra of thor
ragnarok could easily be summed up as
out with the old and in with the new
from killing off characters like the
Warriors 3 to cutting out dr. Selvig and
the earth Browne settings of the first
two movies
Ragnarok blew the franchise wide open by
creating a movie that brought a whole
new ensemble of characters into a
galaxy-wide romp that had very little to
do with the Thor franchise of old one of
the major developments that this massive
overhaul brought about was the
introduction of Valkyrie I used to want
to be in South Korea when I was younger
so I found out that you were old women
there's nothing wrong with women of
course I love women sometimes a little
too much Foster and Valkyrie are
difficult to compare on the one hand
that Foster's heroics come from a
research and scientific brilliance on
the other of our careers Valkyrie is a
really any competition in the comic
books faster continues to develop into
something more than a mere mortal but in
the MCU she remained somewhat shackled
by her humanity
with the MCU style becoming increasingly
cosmic they wouldn't get any easier for
her to keep up it would only be natural
however for valkyrie to fill the role of
the franchise's long-term female lead
ragnaroks throwaway breakup line
dispatches Jane from the movies plot as
quickly as possible while still leaving
a door open for her return in the future
sorry I hear that Jane dumped you she
didn't dump me you know doctors mutual
dumping but the fact remains that the
story just doesn't have much use for her
anymore
as recently as February 2018 Robin made
it clear that she was open to returning
to the MCU at this point however there
might not be much point rather than
being detrimental Thor's character some
distance from his relationship seems to
have given the god of thunders tail a
bit of a boost in the short space of two
movies the folks a Marvel have managed
to weave so many new elements into his
character arc but at the end of the day
Foster's Sedan absence is more of an
afterthought than the loose plot thread
it could have been it's never easy to
keep a relationship going when you've
got a lot on your plate and Thoris got a
loss on his even during a time when Jane
Foster was still clearly in the picture
Thor I'd been running around the
universe saving civilizations left and
right and seemed to be having to make
excuses about being absent for so long
without touching base and that's not all
Thor was also about to deal with the
death of both his parents
Frigga who was murdered by Dark Elves
and Odin who vaporized before his very
eyes and let's not get into the whole
Loki thing surprise recently things
haven't gotten much better after Odin's
death in Ragnarok Thor was forced to
take on the duties of Asgard King which
mostly involved keeping his siblings in
check and attempting to prevent Ragnarok
itself which well didn't really go so
well
and then to top it all off Thor was
forced to watch as his redeemed brother
was murdered by Thanos a tragedy which
kicked off a whole new series of
problems for Thor can you really blame
him for letting his relationship slip in
the end sometimes the simplest answer is
the best one Jane Foster and Thor are
clearly not compatible with each other
sure they met when Thor was in mortal
form and it's not exactly 30 feet tall
or green or made of rocks but how long
were they ever really going to last
celeb couples can manage to cope with a
significant age difference if they
really do try hard but your Asgardian
boyfriend being over 1500 years old is
bound to cause trouble eventually was
drunk I like it I know even when you're
trying to have a simple lunch day the
fact is that Thor is a guard and Jane
isn't at this point you can pretty
safely assume that their breakup was for
the best
Jane can go on studying and doing good
for mankind or for can continue to fly
around saving the universe and no one's
feelings ever need to get hurt
[Music]